- What up vlog.
This is keynote I gave in
Oslo a couple weeks ago.
Super excited about it.
Really felt strong.
Thought a lot of insights
that I haven't touched on
in the past were extracted.
The tremendous Oslo, Oslo stand up!
Incredible crowd in Oslo,
extracted some interesting
insights and I hope you enjoy it.
Real state of the union
where my mind is at
when it comes to attention and framework
and strategy around how to succeed.
Enjoy, enjoy, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
Oslo get ready for the single best keynote
in the history or this wonderful country
is about to be given.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you Oslo.
- [Man In Crowd] I love you!
- I love you back, bro.
(audience laughter)
It's always good when you
bring your brother to a talk.
(audience laughter)
So, you know, I love this format,
I really appreciate this format.
The give a talk, then we'll
do some Q and A together,
then we'll bring you guys in.
And so, what I want to
accomplish in part one here
is to create a framework
of some of the things
that may inspire some questions in detail
when we get to that part.
I think what excites me more than anything
as I sit here this morning
is that we are living through
such an interesting time.
One that I think is quite binary.
I'm curious what's going
through people's minds.
As a matter of fact, real quick,
because I asked some questions,
did a little homework.
How many people here are
in the B to B business,
raise your hands.
So this is exciting for me,
because that's quite a bit,
and it was interesting
what I was thinking about
on my flight last night.
I think that there's a
lot of misconceptions,
assumptions, curiosities, difficulties,
for a lot of B to B marketers,
for a lot of entrepreneurs,
for a lot of consumer based companies.
I think it's a very binary debate.
I really think that we're
in a place right now
where you either believe in
what I think is happening
or you don't.
And I think, I want everybody
to listen to that sentence
very carefully, not about what's coming,
not what's about to happen.
What's happening, versus
believing that or not.
And so what I mean by that is
I believe a lot of the
things that are happening
on the mobile device,
and most importantly,
the attention of the end
consumer is not debatable.
And I think that a lot
of people continue to
conjure up statements like,
yes Gary, in a couple of years.
Or soon, or it's coming,
or we can feel it.
All these things that
allude to its non-reality,
and to be very frank, I'm not
frustrated or disappointed.
To be very frank, I don't
give a shit what you do.
I really don't.
You know, to me, I'd love
to inspire, you know,
when I give a talk like this
and I see all these faces,
my really big hope is that
one person sees something
in the words that are said today
that makes them take this more serious.
Mainly, to be very honest with you,
from a selfish place that
I want you to email me
in three years and say
in 2017 you were in Oslo,
you said this about B to
B marketing on LinkedIn,
I finally listened, and this happened.
I live a life where I get
hundreds of emails a day
from entrepreneurs, B to
B companies, corporations.
I had a guy fly in to a wine tasting I did
for my family business last week,
his company went from $300,000
to $60 million in sales
in 18 months on the back of Facebook ads
and Instagram influencers.
I wish on all of you the
feeling it feels like
when you actually do something
nice for another human being
when you ask for nothing in
return, and you can build,
to your point, that legacy.
My friends, I have no vested interest
in this technology revolution.
I was super happy pre internet, I'm old.
I turn 42 in a couple weeks.
I lived pre internet, I
am not a technologist.
I didn't own a computer
until I was 18 years old.
I don't give a shit about
gadgets, I don't like VR,
I don't like AR, I don't like Facebook,
I only like one thing, attention.
(audience laughter)
And so obviously it
manifests as a human being
and I like this feeling, and
I'm more comfortable right now
doing this than even in
any other environment.
But more importantly, I
like attention much more
on a macro.
Where do our customers spend their time,
and how do we create,
in those environments,
to create the thing that we want.
I started VaynerMedia seven years ago,
not with he intent to build an agency
and sell it to a holding company,
I built it because I want to build
a communications Death
Star, so that I can point it
with any ambition I have.
Whether that's to sell a sneaker,
whether that's to raise money
for my brother's Crohn's disease,
whether that's to help a friend become
the mayor of New York in 20 years,
whether that's to sell a
t-shirt, a bottle of wine,
it's agnostic.
It's agnostic.
Ultimately it's going to
be to use it for propaganda
to make everybody in
America a New York Jets
American Football fan.
But, for the time being, I
continue to hone these skills.
I sit here today believing
in Alexa's skills,
and Amazon's big push
for Alexa and Google Home
and the future Apple Home
Pod, I believe in that space
not because it's showing ROI today,
but my intuition on
consumer behavior tells me
in 36 months, in 48 months,
every single person here
is going to interact with an
AI based speaker or device
and do search queries and buy products
and interact in that environment.
We're living through, my
friends, let's take a step back.
We're living through the biggest shift
in the way humans interact with each other
since the printing press.
This internet thing is a big deal.
This is not about Facebook or Twitter
or Instagram or Snapchat,
this is about the internet
is finally at true scale,
and we're starting to really
understand it's impact.
And it's having obviously
geopolitical impacts,
and I just feel that the audacity amongst
the B to B environment,
and GE is a client,
and we do things with SAP,
and I'm a start up investor
in tons of SAAS businesses
and B to B business.
I think there's a gross misunderstanding
on how much commerce and
actual business results
happen in the new environments
in a B to B world,
and let me explain.
The trick for the B to
B players in this room
is that they have to
understand the cadence
on how they have to communicate
in this new environment
that completely
differentiates from the way
that you would communicate
as a consumer product.
For example, the way I think about
the haves and the have nots,
the binary people that believe
or don't believe right now
in this environment plays
out in a different way.
I call it headline readers
versus practitioners.
There's a lot of people here
who've read an article or two,
who've talked to some people over dinner
and have enormous
opinions on what Facebook
or LinkedIn or Instagram
or blogging or a podcast
can do for their business,
yet they've never
executed a single podcast,
never ran a single Facebook ad,
and have never tried segmentation creative
and media executions in
a LinkedIn environment.
The reason I keep a GaryVee brand,
besides the fact that I love attention,
is because I need to be a practitioner.
In the green room before I came out here,
I literally posted on Instagram
and thoughtfully thought
about the hashtags that I was going to use
to make sure that people discovered it.
I pondered the copy that was
going to support the video
that I was putting out, I
watched the video three times
to catch the energy that I thought.
I thought about the time
it was in New York City
this morning, and that
L.A. would not see it
because it was going to be too early,
and more my European fans would.
The depth of thoughtfulness
on timing and creative
and cadence that I thought
about a single Instagram post
is completely poo-pooed by
the modern B to B environment,
it is not thought about at
any kind of strategic level,
and the reason that most
people fail in winning
in social media is because of
a couple of huge misconceptions.
Number one, there is no social media.
Social media is a slang
term that we came up with
for the websites and
apps now that dominate
the end consumer's
attention in our society.
If you're willing to look
at social media, the word,
the way I am, which is, the
apps that live on the cell phone
that have most of the
attention of the human race
and is the current state
of the actual internet,
all of a sudden, social
media doesn't feel so small
or a sprinkle, or a nice to have,
or the thing that is coming.
Number two, I just don't think
people think it's a craft
or a strategy or an art
to the way that I do.
It is far, somebody who has
run television, run print,
built his family's liquor store business
on the back of email and Google.
As somebody who has lived
in marketing every day
for the last 20 years,
there is has been nothing
more complicated or
difficult to be successful in
than social, because, especially
in a Facebook and LinkedIn
environment where the
action for this room is,
it is the birth child of
television and direct mail
and Google all in one platform.
Most people in the world of business today
have not quantified the difference between
marketing and branding and sales.
Most people either sit
on the side of math,
and are quant based marketers,
or sit on the side of art,
and are creative, subjective marketers,
and they don't realize
that the mix of the two
and the discipline to respect
the tension of both sides
in today's environment is
the brilliance and need
to be successful.
And so as somebody who
has been a practitioner
at attacking that skillset,
not only for myself,
but for the biggest brands in the world,
on the back of an 800 person agency
that does all quant and qual work,
I have a very unique perspective
and I'm very intrigued by it.
I'm very intrigued by how
many people think it is better
to spend money on a print
ad in a B to B magazine
than it is to run Facebook ads.
I'm intrigued by so many people here
that are so much quicker to
spend for the 8th year in a row
25,000 euros to sponsor
a fucking conference.
(audience laughter)
Instead of running $25,000
dollars of LinkedIn ads
against the employees of
companies that they're trying
to reach with creative that
would actually make them
intrigued or inspired
to do business with you.
I am super intrigued by the fact,
how many people here
own their own business,
raise their hands.
And how many do not?
Fantastic.
I'm intrigued by the
difference of those two groups.
I live in a world right
now which is broken up
between Silicon Valley, Madison Avenue,
entrepreneurs and corporates.
I like them all very
much, I love all people,
and I especially love all business people.
But it is not the second
group of hands fault,
the employees, it is impossible,
you're a human being,
it is impossible for you to
spend the money of the company
as if it was your own.
It's just not humanly possible.
It's just not the way we're wired.
And I watch every day two
very distinct things happening
in the market today.
Entrepreneurs, or people
that own their own business,
every day moving ungodly amounts of money,
into influencers, into
Facebook, into LinkedIn.
Not into, be careful here,
I am not a traditional
versus digital debtor.
For example, I believe
that most of the money
spent today on digital is
going directly in the garbage,
because most of the money in digital today
is spent on programmatic
banner and pre-rolls
on websites that nobody's
paying attention to,
and there's no context for the creative,
it's just hitting the CPM
value, or the impression value,
it has nothing to do with
driving the business results.
So this is not a traditional
media is dead, digital is here.
I have more issues with most
digital, it's about today.
It's about day trading attention.
It is you are trying to sell jet engines
or shipping supplies or a SAAS business,
and you have $10,000 to make that happen,
what are you going to do with it,
and to me that's when
you need to understand
the day trading of attention.
What's under priced and
overpriced attention.
If you're in America and
you want to sell product
to an under 30 year old
kid, a pair of sneakers,
Snapchat should have 50% of your money,
regardless of how good of
a deal Snapchat's stock is,
because that is the end
consumer's attention.
And so, we're living through a time
where the biggest businesses in the world
are vulnerable because
distribution of information
and products have been
commoditized by the internet.
The distribution of attention,
or the information to us,
has been commoditized.
Nobody here was shooting
a satellite into space
to start a TV network 20 years
with that capital
infrastructure, and the cameras,
and the studios, but
literally every one of you
in your pocket right
now has live television,
literally, for free, on
Facebook Live or Instagram Live.
I mean, it is remarkable,
we have completely
taken for granted,
completely taken for granted,
the power that we sit on
in our hands right now.
The recording that you're doing right now
used to cost 10's of thousands
of dollars in equipment,
literally just 30 years ago.
We are completely misunderstanding
where the attention is.
We are misunderstanding the
single biggest opportunity
for every B to B company here,
and that is to act like a media company,
not an advertiser.
The biggest problem for all
the B to B companies here is
that it's hard to
advertise B to B products.
And so what happens when it's hard?
It becomes very vanilla.
You show three people smiling
in a fucking office, right?
And you put it on a piece
of paper on page 87,
and you think something
good's going to happen
in 20 fucking 18.
It's what happens.
We know it.
Or you make a flyer and
you send it in the mail,
and you think that's a good idea in 2018.
How many people here can't
wait to leave this conference
and go home and carefully go
through their direct mail.
(audience laughter)
Yeah.
So, so what happens is we have
no cadence or understanding
or creative output, yet, everybody here
can take those same dollars
and do a six part miniseries
in audio form, and create
a six part documentary
in podcast form around the
behaviors in their industry,
or creative that's
interesting to their users.
For example, I have a lawyer friend
who's starting a golf podcast
because he's trying to reach
high net worth individuals,
and a lot of them play golf.
He's not starting a lawyer podcast,
because nobody wants to listen to that.
He's starting an interest
podcast as a gateway drug
to his services, because
the law firm is bringing you
the golf information.
And so, if I can leave
with anything, if anything,
if I can get one of the hands that went up
from the B to B environment in this room,
if I can get one of them
to actually make the shift
that in 2018 instead of spending
hundreds of thousands of
dollars on print and sponsorship
and direct mail as an advertiser,
we're going to look at
the digital landscape
and become a media company
and bring value and interest
to our perspective
clients as a gateway drug.
That would be a huge accomplishment
to make a little less altruistic
and lofty and confusing,
even if you just started
writing white papers
that were not sales release,
but were actually white papers.
If you get out of sales
and you get into branding,
if you make a white paper
about trends in your industry
and why you're servicing them, right.
If you made a white
paper that was 13 pages,
thoughtful, smart, you
put energy behind it,
your best people behind it.
And you ran that on LinkedIn and Facebook
against the employees, and
this is how you segment,
in an ad form, against the employees
of the companies that you
aspire to do business with,
you would see remarkable results.
Because what attention is
most interesting to me.
How many people here have ever played in
the real estate industry in their careers,
raise your hands, just curious.
This is interesting to me.
I've started realizing huh,
I'm acting and navigating this world
like I'm in the real estate business.
You're attention is no different
than real estate people
look at new places, new
beach front properties,
emerging cities, trends within
cities that make you think
the property is under priced.
All I do for a living every
day is what's under priced
and what's overpriced,
and market by market.
What's happening in Oslo that
isn't happening in New York.
Or what's happening in New York,
and one of the great, I
mean, unbelievable advantages
of being in a market that is not the
United States of America is
being able to watch the trends
and understanding which
ones will transfer and not.
Not every app will pop in the Nordics
that pop in America, however,
90% of all of this that I'm talking about
is human, not cultural.
These are human dynamics,
let me give you one.
Everybody here will give
up privacy for time.
Time is the pillar asset for us besides
health, money, and religion.
Time.
So, when I think about
audio and why I push you
to thinking about a podcast,
is because if you're trying to reach
a high net worth individual,
or a decision maker
in a business that would
do business with you
in a B to B environment, I'm
going to make the assumption,
that I think we all
can, is that she's busy.
And what audio does, how many people here
follow my content, raise your hands.
Thank you.
Of the people that, keep your hands up,
I wanted the other people
to see this, thank you.
Look around if you're in the front, okay.
No it's not enough, don't worry,
that's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is watch now this.
Okay, thank you.
Now, of those people, how
many of you in the last year
have started listening more to my podcast
and watching less of my
video, raise your hands?
That.
That's what I am most
intrigued by right now.
To me, thank you.
To me, the fact that
technology in 2018 and 19
is moving us as humans
to act more like people
from the 1930's to 60's
and consume more radio,
because we have it on us,
because we are subconsciously
trying to find more time,
because time is emerging as an asset
because we're getting
pounded with information.
Because we are starting to get trained,
we grossly underestimate
the brain and human beings,
we're starting to get trained
to listen to the podcast
and do something else.
And so, I am betting on voice,
both podcast and Alexa
skills and Google Home
and all those skills,
because I know that is the
thing we're going to buy into.
One of my great misses in
my investment career, Uber,
which I passed on twice in the angel round
at a four million dollar valuation,
I invested in later at a
100 million dollar valuation
because I realized Uber
wasn't selling transportation,
Uber was selling the perception of time.
When you hit that button,
you're able to go on
and do what you're doing
until it gets there,
and that was the remarkable insight.
So much of what you do every
day, the things you value.
Do you know why you don't
unsubscribe from emails
that you have no interest in getting?
Time.
It takes you longer to
unsubscribe to the email
than it does to just
delete it or swipe it out.
Time is driving so much of our behavior,
and in the B to B environment,
in the B to B environment,
it is emerging more to me strategically
because the decision makers
we're desperate to reach
value time even more,
and that's why they will not
go through their direct mail.
That is why they will not go
through a magazine carefully
and stumble on your advertisement.
Can we, Oslo, can we make a deal.
Can you not buy a print
fucking ad next year.
(audience laughter)
I mean I'm sitting here and
I'm talking, and I'm like,
then the other part of my brain is like,
yeah this is so ridiculous,
like how the fuck you
buy a print ad in 2018,
it makes no sense.
It's so overpriced.
Do you know that you pay
eight to 12 times circulation
as the CPM cost for a print ad,
in case Jorge leaves
the magazine on the bus,
and Susan picks it up and goes to page
90 fucking seven and sees your ad.
The lack of practically is so obnoxious.
Yet, there are people here
who comfortably buy print ads
because that's what we've always done
while asking what the ROI
of Facebook and LinkedIn is.
Just incredible times, and
you will see some of the
biggest companies in the
world over the next decade
completely vanish off
the face of the earth
because of their misallocation
and their misunderstanding
of where the consumer's attention is.
They will not understand.
They will go out of business.
This is happening, it's
happening faster than you think,
you see it all around the world.
I was in Singapore last week,
the number two magazine media
company shut down it's print.
It's happening every single day.
In America, Toys "R" Us,
the biggest toy retailer,
out of business, out of business.
This is happening every single day
and will continue to accelerate,
and I'm stunned that I go to a dinner
every night of the week where
for the first 30 minutes
a 70 year old executive
will want to talk to me
for 30 minutes how he
or she cannot believe
that Facebook has changed
the election in the U.S.,
changed the Brexit, it's unbelievable.
They should shut it down,
we need laws, this is crazy,
it's too powerful, it's super scary,
what about our grandchildren.
And then we will transition
to the 30 minutes
of the business talk
and they'll say to me,
but my customers aren't on Facebook.
(audience laughter)
That's what I do every time, too,
I throw up directly on them.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
It's time, it's time we have
the proper conversation,
which is the following.
Most things that we grew
up with five years ago,
banner ads and pre-rolls
included, are overpriced.
It's not that anything's dead.
And I hate when people
are like, TV's dead.
TV's not dead, you know, radio's not dead,
they're overpriced.
What you pay for is not what you get.
Meanwhile, everybody in
here will read an article
in six years that says 2012
to 2019 was a golden era
of Facebook Ads, and you
should have done more.
And now that they're $48
CPM instead of $7 CPM,
you'll regret and you'll be sad, right.
That's what happened to me.
When I get introduced and people say,
he built his dad's liquor
store from three to
60 million dollars, and
everybody's like, I get sad.
Because I spent too much
money on print and outdoor
and radio and all the other things,
even though it was staring me in the face
that Google, for five and
10 and 11 cents a click
was driving unbelievable ROI.
I took it for granted, I was
too young and didn't understand
how good of a deal it was,
and that's why I stand
passionately up here today
and tell you every penny you
can afford to put into Facebook
and create videos and
pictures to make it work,
every penny you can afford
for the B to B players
to put into LinkedIn
and create white papers
and videos for them, every
penny you can afford.
Because you will go back
and look at this era,
much like many of you did with
Google in the early 2000's,
and then you did it in 2010 and 12 and 15,
and you're like, and you caught up.
The problem was, now you're
paying the appropriate price,
you're not stealing it like everybody did
from 2001-2006, that is what's happening.
Either I'm right or I'm wrong,
it will play itself out.
But I will tell you this.
When I see, how many of
you are familiar with Wish,
the shopping app, raise your hands.
Wow, that in itself.
18 months ago if I asked that question,
four hands would have put up.
One more time, how many of
you are familiar with Wish?
How many of you have
boughten something off Wish?
Fuck, this all makes sense.
Listen to this.
Wish, in the last seven
years, or six years,
has gone from zero,
zero, to anywhere between
three to five billion dollars in sales.
It is probably the most
emerging, most important retailer
in the world, that most people don't know.
Yet, it is a top 50 app in
every single app store country
on Apple in the world.
All of their money, all of their
money until this last year,
where they put some branding
on the Lakers jersey's
and on the Mayweather
McGregor fight in the corner,
all of their money for the last six years
has been spent on Facebook.
And these were engineers
that were employees
from Google and left.
Why?
Because they saw the pattern
recognition that I saw,
which was Amazon.
Amazon was Google's biggest advertiser
in the early days of Google.
And they used that under price attention
to build a monster company.
And that's exactly what
these Wish founders did.
They knew that Google was
under priced for those years,
they knew that Facebook was
the new under priced model.
They went all in, all in,
and they bought under priced attention,
acquired customers at
a under priced nature,
and built against that momentum.
That environment is still
available for the next 24 months
for the majority of this room,
including the people
that are practitioners
and understand that you
can target employees
of organizations on Facebook,
and I highly recommend that
you do not take this talk
for granted, and you go
back home after today,
and you start Googling,
how do I run Facebook ads
for my B to B SAAS list.
How do I do this, how do I do that.
The tactics are commoditized,
you can Google it at home.
The mindset to understand what
year we're actually living in
is the punchline of this conversation.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Awesome, Gary, awesome.
My friend Rick bought me this.
- I like this.
- Yeah, it's a Jets hat.
- I like the Jets.
- And I realized that it
doesn't really make any sense
to give it to you.
- Okay.
- Because you probably
have thousands of them.
- I have 7,000 of them yes.
- But I still have it, so.
- Should we sign it and
give it to somebody else?
- That's cool, yeah.
- Yeah, we'll do that. Okay.
- We'll do that.
- Okay.
- Okay, cool.
So sit down here please.
- Sure.
- Some water, Red Bull.
We're going to have a
lot of fun with these,
by the way.
You've heard about this, Catchbox?
- Of course.
I fucking speak every day.
- You're so trendy.
Sorry.
- No worries
- Okay, so, we are going to
have a little conversation
and then you guys can
already start thinking
about all the cool questions
you're going to ask.
But I just want to start.
- Please.
- First of all, welcome back to Oslo.
- Thank you.
- How are you feeling.
- Great, great.
- Yeah?
- Thank you so much guys, for the energy.
Really appreciated it.
(audience applause)
- So the room is filled
with business people.
- Yep.
- And as we talked about
before you hit the stage,
Norway's quite ahead in terms of digital.
- 100%.
- Snapchat is bigger than Instagram here.
And I would say the average Norwegian
uses social a lot.
- [Gary] I agree.
- But still, I get the vibe
from the advertising industry
that a lot of businesses
are still very behind
on investing in Facebook
ads, Google AdWords,
all that jazz, as you
were just describing,
over 70 year old dinner meetings
with 70 year old people.
- And you know why that is, right?
- Tell me.
- It's not a Norwegian thing,
it's not a Nordic thing,
it's a global thing.
It's because the biggest holding companies
that are the fortified
biggest holding companies
in the advertising industry, the WPP's,
the Omnicom's, the Publicis,
these are publicly traded companies
who should be driving
their business results,
not their clients results,
are always selling things that
they make the most margin on,
which is television and
programmatic digital,
and then they will support
it with bullshit reports
that are an inside the game dynamic
to justify the spend, and
they are extracting the value
out of the biggest companies in the world,
so they feel comfortable with the reports
and the bullshit fucking
metrics that they measure on
internal MMM's.
And so it's a complete inside,
did you see the Big Short,
the movie the Big Short?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's what's happening
in the advertising world.
Everybody's in on it.
The company's are fucking getting fucked,
they're gonna lose.
The biggest media companies are getting
bigger and bigger and bigger
and more and more profitable,
and that's why it's happening.
- So, basically, they should
fire their agencies then?
- Um, no, I don't think
it's their agency's fault,
I think it's their fault.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Agencies aren't stealing their money.
They're giving the agencies the money.
- [Interviewer] That's true, so.
- I think what should
happen is we should start
changing the way we compensate the C-Suite
of the biggest companies in the world,
because all of them are
making decisions based on
what the stock price is when they leave
so they can liquidate and buy their yacht,
not if Red Bull's going
to be around for 30 years.
- [Interviewer] Damn.
(audience applause)
- And you know what's funny.
- Yeah?
- They all know it.
I was watching, you guys all know it.
I mean, I know I'm right,
and you know I'm right.
Now, that doesn't mean anything.
Doesn't mean it's going to change.
It just means there's
an opportunity, right.
When companies that have
a lot more money than you
are throwing 95% of their
money directly in the garbage,
you have a change of winning.
Wine.com had 114 million
dollars in fundraising
when I had $14,000 in advertising in 1997.
I beat them.
Why?
Because I did the right
thing for the business,
not because I was an executive
trying to maximize my personal wealth.
- Right.
Do you then think that, like,
entrepreneurs and small
businesses have a bigger chance
to win now than ever?
- 100%.
It's happening.
This is not me predicting.
What the fuck do you think has happened
in the last 10 years?
This is the greatness era because money,
let's say you want to
start a toothpaste brand.
You're passionate about toothpaste.
You want to make more
all natural toothpaste,
and you want to sell it.
You can now sell that
direct to consumer at scale
at a level we've never seen before,
but if you wanted to
start that 25 years ago,
the amount of money you had to pay Tesco
or Saintsbury, or Wal-Mart,
just for trade dollars,
distribution, like of course.
And then if you actually
run Snapchat and Instagram
and Facebook influencer
ads instead of billboards
or print or direct mail,
I mean, absolutely.
This is an incredible time
to act like an entrepreneur,
whether you're an
entrepreneur or a corporation.
And when I say act like an
entrepreneur, you're scared.
You know, the reason I
became a great marketer,
was because the marketing
was for my dad's liquor store
and that's how my family ate.
I wasn't going for Cannes Lion Awards.
I wasn't looking at reports every 90 days
that were metrics on
the brand health lift.
This was about fucking selling pinot noir.
And so I got very disciplined
that marketing had to
do something for you,
not make you feel good about
justifying that you're a CMO.
- Right, and I saw you at
Cannes Lions this year,
just like other big agencies.
So, the things you're preaching
and you're communicating
to us today, how, I mean,
acting like all the others.
Going to Cannes, having
meetings, having parties,
all that kind of things.
How do you make sure
that your whole company
are kind of communicating
the same things you are doing
and making them understand
how to prioritize
the client's budgets in a different way?
- Dictatorship.
(audience laughter)
- Sounds like fun.
- It is fun.
I mean, especially when
you're pushing good.
It's super fun.
If I see tendencies from a leader,
Eric here who's in the
front and runs our UK office
and most of our European activities.
If I get any indication that
Eric is pushing something
that is in the short
term value of VaynerMedia
because he wants the P
and L of the London office
to look better and he knows
that the client will buy this,
but it's not on message,
he won't have a job,
and he knows that.
And it's not, that's not bad.
That's just to make sure we don't lose.
Like, to me, I'm not
scared to go to conferences
and have a party.
To me that's a framework.
You know, that's like being a human being,
we're all the same.
It's about what's coming out of our mouths
and what our actions are.
I am met with a lot of cynicism.
You said it.
You expect much, you'll love this.
How many people here
when they first saw me
or consumed my content,
thought I was a douche bag
or completely full of
shit, raise your hands.
Right, so like, I'm aware of that.
And the good news is
that doesn't cripple me,
because I can deliver or I can't.
Either you're right or I'm right.
And that's kind of how I
feel about Vayner right.
Like I'm not worried
about going to Cannes,
because I go to Cannes and
have this conversation.
You know, having sizzle, or
looking like everybody else
in the front is irrelevant.
It's the execution on the backend
that is going to ultimately
be the case, right.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, absolutely.
- When you and I took
that picture years ago,
I was amongst other social media experts
that were charlatans that
were going to take opportunity
in this short window.
I laughed because I was already
a 33 year old businessman
who'd already built an actual business,
I wasn't a real estate agent
six months earlier, right.
I just truly believed that the
attention of all these people
was going to be in these things.
There's videos of me, you know, in 2013,
a hell of a lot chubbier, saying like,
Snapchat's going to happen,
either I'm right or I'm wrong.
This is not, you know, super complicated.
I said here, it's on video,
that voice is going to matter,
and all of you are going to interact
with speakers in four years.
And if you don't, people are
going to pull up those videos
and say don't listen to Gary,
look how wrong he's been.
So I don't predict, you know,
every time there's new app,
I don't do what a lot of other people do,
and just say this is going to be big
and hope one of them is.
I don't fucking guess, I don't hope.
I fucking work and I execute.
- [Interviewer] Sure, I like that.
(audience applause)
When we tweeted out that
you're going to visit us today,
I got a lot of questions
about VaynerMedia in Europe
and in the Nordics.
Can you maybe share a little bit
about your plans there?
- Look, we have ambition
to service the globe
in a 40 year macro.
And so, you know, obviously,
a lot of people in Nordics
saw what we did with ArticStartup,
and we have 10 teammates
coming to Helsinki in January,
like we're looking at
this part of the world
very feverishly.
I'm a very big fan of the time
I've spent in the Nordics.
And I'll be, you know, look.
I think a lot of you do watch my content.
I don't go to every place
and be like, I like you.
I do like this place.
There's a really, you know,
it's interesting right.
So I'm funny with Europe
because I disrespect it,
because even though I was born in Belarus
and born in Eastern Europe, like,
there's, like I'm a work ethic guy.
And I'm very empathetic
to like work life balance
and quality of life, I don't
just anybody's opinion.
But like, in business,
I do think work ethic
is super hardcore important,
and I think certain parts
of the world have it
too extreme and work
too hard, and I think,
I think New York is one
of them, I really do.
Even though I work harder than them,
I can take back a step
subjectively and go, that's a lot.
And then there's other parts of the world
that don't work at all,
like Greece and shit, right.
(audience laughter)
And I'm like, you're
fucking losers, right.
And so, but it's been interesting.
And I've been to the
Nordics maybe 12, 13 times.
I think there's an
interesting cadence here,
I think there's interesting brands here,
I think there's interesting
businesses here,
and we have real ambitions.
Obviously for people
that follow me the most,
they saw that I kind of
ran my mouth and said
we'll be in Singapore in
2018 with VaynerMedia,
which I would say is 95% accurate.
And so, we're looking at Southeast Asia
very aggressively right now.
But, over the next 20 years,
the Vayner brand will have a
flag in every sector, right.
You know, South America and
Africa, we will be everywhere.
And so, we will be here.
- Cool.
- Timing, I don't know.
And so, I started referring
to the jab jab method
when I work with my clients.
Focus on giving value
and the right to market,
is that still a very
important thing to focus on
in your opinion, and what
are the big lines of advice
you usually give to your
clients, like high level.
- For a lot of people that don't know,
I wrote a book several years ago called
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
Give, give, give, and then ask.
I think a lot of people
when they put out content
are ask, ask, ask, ask, or
take, take, take, take, right.
I think what has really
worked for me and the clients
that I've worked with and the start ups
that I've worked with is
when you actually give value,
and a lot of times people
think they're giving value,
but if you look carefully
it's selfish, right.
So these are nuances.
But yeah, I think it's
never been more important
to be what I would call consumer centric.
A lot of people here talk in boardrooms
about being consumer centric,
but advertising in general
already is not consumer centric.
You want to steal my time to
tell me how good your soda is.
That's not inherently consumer centric.
And so, more than ever
I believe in empathy.
I think empathy is the secret
drug of success in our society
both as a leader, when you're a boss,
and definitely when you
think about the consumer.
And I think that the trait of empathy
that I took from my mother is no question,
maybe outside of competitiveness
that I took from my dad,
the core reason why I sit here today.
And if anything I would tell
you if I wrote it again,
I would it call it,
Jab, Jab, Jab, Jab, Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
It's just more important because
there's so much being thrown out, right.
As the supply of content and noise grows,
you have to differentiate
with more value, not less.
And so, again, trying to
speak to the people here
who have been following me,
you've seen in the last
18 months compared to
the prior five years,
I've been more aggressive
of putting out free
information and good content.
In written, in audio, in
video, in multiple shows.
Like I'm going harder to bring value
because I felt like it was the only way
that I could separate and
create the opportunities
that I wanted for myself, was basically,
I basically think I'm
trying to guilt people
into being interested in what I'm doing
by providing so much more
value with nothing in return
that it almost creates a level of guilt.
- Yeah, I see that.
I've noticed that you've switched from,
you're a lot more motivational
in your content now,
then you were earlier.
- I agree.
- And I remember that you
said in an interview once,
that you're very afraid of being looked at
as a motivational speaker.
- Desperately fearful, yes.
- So, what changed?
- Why did I do it?
I built another 150 million
dollar revenue a year business
and it made me feel good
that if you called me
a motivational speaker,
I would say, that's fine.
But have you been paying
attention to the fact
that I grew the fastest
growing agency in the industry
in parallel.
So by building an actual business,
and by actually being a
CEO, and by actually again,
not just Wine Library, but
now again a second time,
building something.
You know, listen.
It's not easy to build
something from zero dollars
and zero cents to 150
million dollars in revenue,
not valuation, in a seven year window.
That takes operational skill.
And so if you don't see
that that's what I've done,
well then that's okay.
But what has allowed me
to be more motivational is
the lack of fear that that was
the only thing I was doing.
I am optimistic.
- [Interviewer] So you got
more confidence and proof.
- 100%.
I felt like I had, you
know, and don't forget
how I figured out the drock thing, right.
He's just filming me, I'm living my life.
It's not like I'm doing that.
GaryVee is my side hustle.
Gary Vaynerchuk CEO of a
large enterprise is what I do,
and so yes I felt more
comfortable, confident,
that I could speak a little
bit to the motivation,
because the truth is it's really scary.
It's, you know, the way I gave this talk.
The tactics are very commoditized.
It's the mindset which gets
into motivational aspects
that is so imperative,
because you're trying
to break through
insecurities in individuals
that lack the courage to do something
and are crippled by fear
because they're worried
about other people's opinions.
I'm trying to push so hard.
I'm basically trying to be their courage
so they can blame me if they
fail, which I'm fine with,
I just want them to do.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and you
think it's easier for people
to do things they're scared
of if they can blame you
at the end if it didn't work.
- 100%.
I really mean that.
And I'm okay with that
because I think that,
I think that people
don't understand how much
they're going to regret
when they're older.
I also think a lot of executives here
are going to get fired in six
years for being conservative,
even though that's what their company's
telling them to do.
They're going to be the
fall guy and the fall gal
when the company starts faltering,
just like the CMO of Under Armour
was just pushed out
yesterday, I met with him,
he was very conservative,
the company was telling him
to be conservative, but
when it hurt Under Armour,
he's the one that's getting
killed, not the CEO.
So a bunch of people here
are going to be out of a job,
they think they're being
smart and a political animal
and they're going to get promoted.
What they don't realize is
that the market's changing
on them and when everybody looks at them
and they were the ones pushing bullshit,
because the company wanted
them to pull bullshit,
they're going to get fired,
and I don't want that to happen to them,
so I'm trying to get them
to die on their sword,
instead of somebody else's.
And I'm trying to focus on
getting them to tell the truth
instead of what they think they need to do
to get another bonus this year.
(audience applause).
- [Interviewer] Cool.
- Thank you, and the
reason they're clapping
is they know how true
what I just said was.
(audience laughter)
And you're clapping yet conflicted,
and I'm empathetic, I
don't think I'm cool,
I don't think you're bad,
I just want to have these conversations
so you can be thoughtful.
Right?
Like maybe it's time to have the courage
to say what you actually believe.
Because let me tell you something,
getting killed on somebody
else's thesis sucks.
You'd rather go down with yours.
(audience laughter)
It's the big one, it's the big one.
It's the one that, again, that's
why the reaction happened.
If I can just give people
courage to go into a meeting
tomorrow and go, you know what.
First of all, they may
not have the skillset
of understanding Facebook
or Snapchat filters
or whatever it may be.
First, you gotta motivate them to go home
and read and watch and
get educated, right.
But if they're here at all,
they're already ahead of 99%.
If they even are here, I've already got.
When I speak, I'm not speaking
in the middle of Red Square,
hoping I can convince a
couple Russians, right.
I'm in conferences where
people have already come,
you're already on third base.
Now it's just which way
are you going to go.
Are you going to go back,
or is this the moment
you're going to go forward.
And I take a huge, I'm flattered
that I was invited here.
I feel obligated to give my
best thoughts and efforts here,
and so that's why I speak
and communicate the way I do.
I'm playing for legacy.
- I like that.
So, I noticed kind of a pattern interrupt
in what you've been doing
with Planet of the Apps.
So, for those of you guys who don't know,
it's your show on Apple Music.
And I would just love your,
because it's more
traditional media, kind of.
I'd love to just hear your thoughts on.
- Why I did it?
- Why I did it and if you got
what you wanted out of it.
- I got what I wanted out of it.
Not all of what I wanted out of it,
but I did it because I love
doing things that are win win,
no matter what happens.
It's why I did the sneaker.
And I'll explain that as well.
But I'll stay to your question.
The reason I did that is
because the other three people
that were my guests, that were my mentors,
are fucking famous as shit, you know.
And by being the fourth, by being Ringo,
but knowing that I was John or Paul,
was a very good strategy, right.
I knew it was a subject matter that I had
much more expertise at, right.
I knew that I was going
to be good on camera,
because I am good on
camera, just I'd never done
a television show.
And I thought the whole time that Apple
would never release it on Apple Music,
because I thought that was awkward,
why would you watch a show on Apple Music,
we didn't get, you know, I don't
like to fight the consumer,
as I was saying in the green room.
You do what the consumer does.
So the whole time, you
know, it took a year
after we signed to coming out.
The whole time I'm like, okay.
They're going to create
something called Apple,
there going to do something with Apple TV,
or they're going to create
Apple Entertainment,
or they're going to buy Netflix.
Like the whole time I thought, there's no,
literally til like the
week before the show aired,
I'm like, there's no way
they're going to distribute this
on Apple Music, so the reason
I didn't get everything
is because it was on Apple Music,
and that was awkward, they didn't watch,
even though it was in
every country in the world.
What I did get, was in 10
episodes for Hollywood,
I put on film that I'm
a celebrity, I'm a star,
and I'm worth doing business with.
And the level of business deals
that I've been offered to do
any business show I want
on the biggest networks
in the world has been remarkable.
Now, ironically, I am so
excited about what's going on
with VaynerX, you know I bought PureWow,
I created a holding company, VaynerMedia,
and I think the stakes
are so high based on what
I've been talking about
with the opportunity
what the holding companies are doing,
that I'm, I was about to say I'm probably,
I'm not going to do a TV show next year,
like I thought I would.
Even though the offers are better
than I could have even imagined.
Because I have to stay
disciplined and be the operator,
because the opportunity is to great,
and so I'm going to see that through.
But, it was great.
And also, I love doing firsts.
Apple is going to figure
out original programming.
And one day I'll be siting at, bro.
(audience laughter)
I get it, respect.
- [Interviewer] Tough crowd, eh?
- Yeah, he better be taking a shit.
(audience laughter)
I know, which is even better.
I wish everybody fucking left
right now and went to work.
I like that I'll be able
to be here in seven years
at this conference.
We'll be talking about
how all the networks died
and OTT won, and I'll be able
to make a reference like,
yeah you know, when I did
the first show on Apple.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- That has value.
And that's how I think.
So it was all upside.
All upside.
By traditional TV, if I
did a regular TV show,
like I was offered a ton,
and it failed, for ratings,
in theory the way this did.
Then I'd have nothing.
Here, I siphoned the brand equity
and had, and I'm completely
on a different pedestal
in Hollywood because I'm
with the other famous people.
It was a show that was
around my strengths,
so I was disproportionally better on it,
so it was a win win.
It's very smart to do business things
where there is no downside.
(audience laughter)
- So, two seconds about your
shoes before my last question.
- Yes.
Literally the same exact thing.
- Yeah?
- Sure, it's the, you know,
out of a top 10 sneaker brand,
it's the first collaboration
where an entrepreneur
has a shoe, not an athlete or a musician.
If it works, then I get to always say
that I had the first
business sneaker, right.
Right?
If it doesn't work, my best
friends get to make fun of me
for having a big ego.
- So last question before
we open up for the audience.
So, you talk a lot about legacy.
- Yes.
- And you're talking about legacy
being greater than currency.
- I do.
- What do you mean by that?
- I'd rather be remembered
as a tremendous human being
than make a couple extra dollars.
I leave money on the table every day.
Way more than people would realize.
Like, my assistants, my
admins, my lawyers, my agents,
they're always freaked out.
Because I make decisions
that are going to look good
when I'm dead, versus making
an extra seven million
dollars a year this year.
And so, when I made
$100,000 a year, I made it.
I came from nothing, you know.
When you're an immigrant and
you live in a studio apartment
with seven family members
and you've got nothing.
When your parents buy you
seven toys your entire life
and you had to buy the rest of them,
when you went on one family vacation
in your entire childhood, like,
you're coming from a different place.
So, like I said, when
I made $100,000 a year
for the first time, when
Wine Library got bigger,
I was like, phew, I made it.
So for me, I'm not driven by the money.
The money will be there,
the money's there now
at a level that I am super excited about.
I know I want to buy the Jets,
but it's the chase of trying
far more than it.
And I think I was,
listen, when I talk about
what I think I have that's special,
I don't think that's an ego or confidence,
I think that's, that's giving my parents
and being an immigrant a pedestal.
When I talk about being good,
I think that's me flattering my parents.
What did I do about it?
You know, my kids, my
businesses I feel pride in.
Me?
That's my parents work.
That's America's capitalism at work.
That's being an immigrant at work.
I have nothing to do with the admiration
that I have for people, so
it keeps me very grounded.
The reason I was nice, you
know, when people meet me,
is I didn't do anything.
I'm the byproduct of Sasha and Tamara,
they should be running
around acting big shots.
I'm fucking, just, you
know, trying to deliver
on the gifts, and I'm
driven, completely fueled,
completely fueled on gratitude.
I'm so grateful for my circumstances,
and that's why I want to give back.
I feel guilty.
The reason I understand out of guilt,
is because I feel that guilt
for having such an unbelievable mother.
I feel that guilt for being born.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
For being born with talents to communicate
that touch people.
I feel guilty for struggling,
which created a skin
that makes all your opinions matter to me
and not matter to me at the same time.
And so, yeah, I really want legacy.
To be very honest with you,
because I feel I was built for it.
Like I, you know, I don't like saying it,
because it does sound so douchey,
but I think I'll be all time.
(audience laughter)
- I love that.
- And let me tell you why,
because I haven't even started.
I'm 41 years old, like.
I have 40, 50 years of
work to put into the world.
And for you and others here,
you've seen what's happened
in one year, compared to a year ago.
The momentum is so exponential,
and that's how it works.
Right, it builds, and it builds.
And what I have is real and it's honest
and I really genuinely
want to give them 51,
because I know what to do with the 49%,
and I watch everybody
else and they want 80,
and they want 90, and they want 100.
And that's why I'll beat them.
- I like that.
So, you said you had
that I made it moment.
- Yeah.
- Many many years ago.
Do you still have those moments.
Are you still, I know you're grateful,
but are you still having
those kind of moments?
- And even that one was
kind of like whatever.
I'm not good at smelling the roses.
- No.
- But I, to your question,
it's an interesting thought,
and I think it affects people around me,
that's why I think about it.
For me, playing the game is the roses.
The process, the struggle, the failures,
is the stuff that gets me going.
Not the accolades, the awards, the money.
I like the game.
I liked four sports teams
in America growing up.
My baseball team and hockey
team won a championship
and I stopped caring.
My football team and my
basketball team still haven't,
and I care quite a bit.
That's me.
I want the climb, I want struggle.
And I've been successful,
and I think most people
are successful when they are
in it for the right reasons.
And if you're an entrepreneur,
the right reasons
are getting punched in the face.
You get punched in the face
everyday as an entrepreneur,
everything's on you, it's
lonely, it's very difficult.
It's been good the last eight years
because the world economy's good,
wait until it gets bad again.
A lot of these kids don't know yet,
they don't know what it feels
like when the world melts,
the money dries up, and
you still gotta survive.
And I've been through two
of those cycles already.
And like, I'm looking
forward to the next one.
I can't wait for the world to melt.
Because all of the C and D
and B players get eliminated
and go get jobs, and I like that.
That's merit, that's
capitalism, that's the game.
And so, I don't smell the
roses when things happen,
because I think I'm smelling the roses
in real time every day.
- I like that.
Ready for some questions?
- I am.
- All right, people.
Can we change the lighting
so we can actually see
all the people as well?
And Dominic, I'll give it to you, catch.
- [Gary] That's fancy.
- [Audience Member] Hi Gary.
- [Gary] How are you, my friend.
- I'm good, love you.
- [Gary] I love you too
man, thanks for the hoodie.
One life baby.
- I'm curious, you talk always about,
you talk always about speed.
It is important.
- [Gary] Yes, very.
- [Audience Member] Hiring is important
and firing is even more important.
- 100%.
- [Audience Member] What is
the process in VaynerMedia?
How long do you, does it take
for you to fire a person.
- Somebody just got approved to be fired
in 90 days today.
Other people, I've been
agonizing for 18 months.
There's no one size fits all, right.
There's two forces, there's
me as an individual,
as the dictator, as
the CEO, as the leader.
And then there's the
collective leadership, right.
And I try to counterbalance
them, I don't blindly,
I don't take my leadership's
opinions blindly,
because they're protecting their lives
and their opportunity,
and so they may be doing the wrong thing.
Subconsciously, they're not bad people.
So, it runs the gamut.
I mean, there was somebody
I hired not too long ago
that I thought was going to be important,
and I basically fired
that person in my mind
48 hours later.
So, the problem, the reason
most people here don't fire
when they're supposed to is their own ego.
They don't want to admit
that they were wrong
in making the selection of the person.
And it is killing so
many of your businesses.
Or, the other reason that they don't fire
is somebody's too important
to their business financially,
even though they're a cancer internally,
which means they're going
to lose long term, too.
And so, I don't do those two things.
I make sure I'm way better than
everybody that works for me,
so I'm never at the mercy of anybody.
(audience laughter)
I'm being serious.
Uh-huh.
And I also am very humble
when it comes to my,
I think I have great EQ,
it's what I trade on,
but I've been so wrong so many times,
because it's so difficult.
And so, they run the gamut.
There's a million different things.
What's unacceptable, what speeds up,
people are fired much quicker for being
not nice to the other boys
and girls much quicker
than not being good at their job.
They can't be disruptive to the energy,
the culture, because I don't
like tension and negativity,
and if you're fucking me
up, you've got no shot.
- [Audience Member] I like
that, thank you very much.
Could you sign two books?
- Yeah, of course.
- Okay, so, Rick, I'm throwing it to you.
- Nice throw.
- [Rick] Can you hear me?
- In a second I think we can.
- Yeah.
- [Rick] Gary, welcome to Oslo.
- Thank you so much my friend.
- I've got two questions.
My first question,
first off I want to say,
thank you for talking
so much about gratitude.
Thank you.
My first question, I'm going
to try to make you jealous.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- I was a 13 year old boy.
I was growing up, I was living
in West Islip, New York.
- [Gary] Yes.
- January 12th, 1969.
- 1969.
Best day on earth.
- I got up at six o'clock in the morning,
because I couldn't sleep.
- [Gary] Awe man, I'm
super fucking jealous.
- Waited until four
o'clock in the afternoon,
what was I doing?
- You were ready for the
New York Jets stunning,
my friends, the Sports Illustrated,
the most important sports
magazine in America
at the time predicted the
Jets would lose the Superbowl,
41 to nothing.
They were the biggest
underdog in Superbowl history,
and they won.
- [Rick] Broadway Joe Namath
against Johnny Unitas.
- That's amazing man, that's so cool.
I'm actually jealous.
- I brought you hat, that was the hat.
- [Gary] Do you have a question?
- The second question is about voice,
because I'm really happy
you're talking about voice.
I just launched a voice app,
which is a voice analysis
technology, called Voiceable.
And what we do with the app,
is we record somebody's voice,
and then we help speakers and presenters
to work on their voice.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- It is interesting, and it
allows you to compare yourself
to some of the greatest speakers
and inspirational speakers in the world.
- So you're breaking down the analytics
of the sounds.
- [Rick] Exactly.
We're making it easy to practice with it.
- Interesting.
- But the number one
celebrity that you can
compare yourself with
is always Barack Obama,
hard to beat, most people want to do it.
But number two, is GaryVee.
- I think you've got your ratings wrong.
(audience laughter)
- [Rick] I may have, I may have.
(audience applause)
- That's amazing, I've got to see that.
- [Rick] So my question is,
there's all these entrepreneurs,
young entrepreneurs who are racing around
and they want to be like GaryVee.
And they're talking fast,
and they're trash talking.
- And you know that scares me, right.
- [Rick] And my comment is,
what kind of comment
would you have to them?
Advice to them?
- I would say for them to be them.
You know, self-awareness,
along with gratitude,
and along with empathy,
is something I'm spending a
lot of time talking about.
It's funny, I come across so alpha,
so when I talk about all
these soft and warm skills,
I'm always fascinated by
how people consume it,
because it's a really curve ball, right.
What I would tell them
is they need to deploy
self-awareness.
What made me me was I was brought up
with so much self-esteem by a mother
that understood its power,
and I had my own DNA
and circumstances, that
I didn't want to be
anybody else.
The level of knowledge I
have on Richard Branson,
Steve Jobs, or Jack Welsh,
or Bill Gates, or Mark.
I know nothing about anybody.
Like, zero.
I've always just focused
on being confident
about what I had, and more importantly,
being humble about what I didn't have.
You can't, you know, when you
try to fabricate charisma,
it comes out as the worst shtick ever.
And we can all taste it.
And so, look, I've double
down and tripled down
and quadrupled down and
continue to on what I have,
and so I try to tell a
lot of these young men,
you know it's been really
interesting for me.
I've been spending an ungodly
amount of time on motivation,
because I think it's a gateway drug
to get a lot of young men into my funnel.
And I think a lot of young men
are very easily swayed
to the wrong things,
because of insecurities and
what kind of things guys want
in their 20's, and I've
been very proud about this
the last year from a legacy standpoint
of getting so many guys to think I'm cool,
because then I systematically
break them down
with my content.
Instead of being disrespectful and
instead of looking for money and girls
and things of that nature,
I start teaching them
tried and true things
that will make them get
everything they've ever wanted,
and be a much better
contributor to society.
- [Rick] Great, thank you
Gary, thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
And let's make sure we bring it up there,
because I always feel like we
always mess that up, right.
It always happens.
- [Audience Member] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [Audience Member] Fine, thank you.
Very inspiring to be here.
- Thank you.
- I have a question, I do sales training
for business to business.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- One of the biggest challenges for them
is to find the right customers
and actually get enough customer meetings
with the right clients.
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- I think that's all over the world,
about the same problem.
- Do you know why?
Because most people in B to B sales
are always talking instead of listening.
The concept is spam everybody
on fucking LinkedIn,
pound them, pound them, pound them,
and nobody wants to talk to them anymore,
which is why they don't
have enough meetings.
Instead of engaging in
content that's being put out
on Twitter and LinkedIn.
Where as if they say something
meaningful in a comment
in LinkedIn, they get
asked to have a meeting,
versus the other way around.
- [Audience Member] And over
here you talked about Facebook
being under priced, and
you talked about this
white paper on LinkedIn.
What is kind of under
priced or right value
meaning to get in contact
with the right clients
for business to business companies.
- The reason I love B to B is you know
who you're trying to reach.
And so when I said listening,
I gave you the tactical way, which is
people are putting out content,
and you can engage with that
content, and they'll see you.
The much better way to listen
is to know the company you're going after,
doing some research for an
hour or two or three days,
and understanding what their
strengths and weaknesses are,
and then things that people blow me away.
For example, in my business.
There's a lot of people I
want to do business with,
but if the CEO is best
friends with Martin Sorrell,
we're not getting that business.
And so, I'm stunned by
sales people's inability
to deal in reality.
I love when sales people are like,
I'm going to break through.
No you aren't, asshole.
You're going to waste time.
And so I think listening,
research, understanding,
instead of blanket spray
and pray, high volume,
cold calls, emails, networking
events, handing cards,
it's just, it's not working.
It's a waste of time and money.
Sometimes the math works
out, I'm not against it,
I love the hustle.
But a lot more listening
and understanding the score,
understanding who you're competing with.
And understanding if that
product, there's happiness,
in the system.
The reason Vayner's grown so quickly
is I paid attention to who was not happy
with their digital work.
I didn't go after brands,
there's a lot of brands
I wish I was working with.
Cereal is my favorite product,
and we don't have a cereal client.
I can't fine the right angle right now
to seeing any of the big
cereal brands upset enough
that it's a good conversation.
Got it?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- So, a lot more, the best
way to be a great sales person
is to be a listener, not a talker.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
- Okay, all the way in the back.
- [Audience Member] Cereal killer.
- Cereal killer.
- Hey, my name's Kurt
and I'm the president
of one of the university's here in Oslo.
- Very nice.
- And university education
is a dying industry.
We're slaves to the campus model,
our government cares only about
getting people through fast enough.
I assume you think
education is a good idea,
but do you see any value for degrees.
- I do see value for degrees
for the short and medium term
if people have a very
specific job they want
and that organization requires a degree.
If you want to be a consultant
at Bain and McKinsey
in the next 24 to 36 months,
I still believe that they care about
where you went to college.
However, and you can hold onto the mic,
because I think we might have
a good conversation here.
However, to you're question
that you're leading,
I think you're barking up the right tree.
I don't think that people realize
that the biggest and best
universities in the world
are only trading on brand, right.
Not on the actual education.
That that actual education
is actually sitting
at the professor level,
not at the university or campus level.
And as education gets commoditized,
you know, distribution of
education gets commoditized,
and things like Khan Academy
and the seven other things
that are about to happen,
if you get the 13 best
professors of economics together.
If I, if I as a great
business man went out
and rounded up the 13 best
professors around economics
and created a direct to consumer economics
training education
platform, we would dominate.
We would dominate, we would win.
Because that's where the IP is.
It's in her and him,
not at the local level.
And so, I think over
the next 20 to 30 years,
this great run of 100
years plus, is coming to.
- [Audience Member] 1,000 years.
- Respect, respect.
Because I'm undereducated.
This great run, it's true, I am.
To your point, is clearly
in a vulnerable place.
And I think every country
has it's own dynamics.
My answer was, you know, in America,
you started getting into the 50's
when everybody had to go to college,
or a community college,
not go vocational, right.
So there's different
dynamics, different cultures
will spend their time
differently in dissolving this.
But I think your energy is right,
I think when somebody watches
this video in 50 years
they're going to say,
wow those guys got it.
- Those guys got it.
Yeah, you know, because
all we really need to do
at the institutional level is, in a sense,
double check and give accreditation
to all the crazy online work experience,
combination of things
that people put together
to make an education.
- And don't forget, and don't forget,
that's just playing on the brand, right.
Putting that seal of
approval is just brand.
- [Audience Member] And
ensuring the quality.
But the idea that we're
going to draw everybody
to move onto campus for
five years to get education,
that's crazy.
- And listen, listen.
The counter argument people will say,
well people have grown
up on these campuses.
I listen to that, I agree, but listen.
Travel around the world then.
You know, like there's
so many alternatives
to putting them on campus
where they can learn
to mature as individuals.
I mean, you're preaching
to the choir on this one.
I think it plays out,
but of course learning is imperative.
But like, you know for me, you know,
entrepreneurship's probably the one
that's most intriguing to me,
because the thought of
learning entrepreneurship
in a classroom versus being in the field,
is just so ludicrous.
And then America has
a weird extra dynamic.
The level of debt our
citizens are going into.
You've got 23 year olds
coming out of college today
with $280,000 in debt at
enormously high interest rates,
and the piece of paper's not getting them
a good job anymore.
I mean, it's really bad in America.
Really bad.
And ironically, it's the one thing
you can't declare bankruptcy
from and clear up.
You can literally be fraudulent
and clean up your credit,
but you can't do it with a college debt.
I mean, it's such a fucking
fraud it makes me throw up.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, that's right.
Me too.
(audience applause)
- Unfortunately Gary, we're
out of time for questions.
- Really?
- Yeah, and the organizers
are really strict about time.
- But can we sneak maybe one more in?
- Yeah, let's be rebels, let's do that.
Fuck that.
- Fight the system.
- Last question.
- Okay clearly that guy.
- Okay this guy, obviously.
- [Gary] That was good marketing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, strong feelings.
- [Gary] I'm telling you,
sound is a voice baby.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
Okay, hi GaryVee, I'm Jan Frederik B.
It's an honor to talk to you.
You were talking about Google,
and the possibility to do
a deal as good as a steal,
then it was Facebook.
Which emerging platforms do you see
with the biggest potential
for steal deal right now.
- Alexa skills and briefings.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
And let me give you
guys why that plays out.
I believe that if you're quick to building
briefings and skills, and if
you don't know the difference
between an Alexa skill
and an Alexa briefing,
you literally just Google it,
and in about 15 minutes
you'll know, got it.
But one is just passive information,
one is more AI and understands and can go
back and forth with you.
I, look, in the same way to your point,
Snapchat's bigger here than Instagram,
and things of that nature.
I always want to give
advice that matters to you.
I don't know how the voice
play plays out in the Nordics,
but here's what I can tell you.
It's going to happen, and
the quicker you understand
the theoretical strategies behind it,
when your thing happens,
you'll be able to move quicker
instead of debating if
it's going to happen.
And that's why I think that's the most.
And I don't usually guess, or I don't,
by day trading attention, you
don't know what's coming next,
you don't care, you only care about today.
But to give you an
insight, I do believe that
is the clear black and
white emerging space
in our society.
- Nice.
- [Audience Member] Amazing, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Okay, so I'm just going to give you some
practical information in Norwegian,
so bear with us.
- Respect.
- And then we're going to thank you
and we're going to give
you a nice applause.
- Great.
I'll check my phone.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We're going to watch a
movie, so, two seconds.
- That's what I thought.
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
- Okay everybody, thank you.
Thank you so much for coming,
and let's give Gary a big applause.
(audience applause)
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Interviewer] And have
a great day, thank you!
(audience applause)
- Leave your four cents,
two points, two bullets,
in the comments and subscribe,
subscribe, subscribe.
So many of you being lazy.
Anyway, none the less,
leave your four cents.
Two bullet points, in the comments, now.
(upbeat music)